wir wollen aber auch einen ganz
besonderen gast begrüßen wir haben auch
in dieser sendung schon oft so über die
nöte der selbstständigen berichtet aber
bei mir im studio ist eine junge dame
die hat absolut da keine probleme sie
hat 2,4 millionen instagram follower das
muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen
herzlich willkommen katja gasser witze
richtig hallo hallo hallo schön schön
dass du da bist
wir hatten hier zum teil immer mal
wieder das thema influenza du bist ja
wahrscheinlich da bombastisch
aufgestellt was wir erzählt du hast du
wahnsinnig vollen terminkalendern wie
geht's in influenza jetzt so in dieser
zeit gibt weniger termine ja kommt
darauf an was für ein fenster mann ist
gibt verschiedene arten und weisen das
ist so riesig also bei mir ist ja so ich
mache verschiedene sachen wie youtube
tik tok
ich mache aber auch musik aber ich bin
auch live auf der tour gewesen und wenn
es jetzt um tour geht was halt schlecht
mit corinna aber wenn es um influenza
erleben geht dann kann man sehr viel
machen man kann sehr viele apps bedienen
man kann sehr viele bewerbungen machen
man kann eigentlich verschiedene dinge
machen das internet läuft immer internet
läuft immer wie ist das so mit dem
finanziellen ist das jetzt eingeschränkt
viele sagen ja möchte ich habe das gar
keine
es gibt keine kampagnen zum beispiel wie
sie bei dir
zum glück gebe ich ja nicht von
kampagnen ich lebe er von meinen fans
und ich habe zum beispiel ein buch
herausgebracht solche sachen kann man
immer machen weil online verhandelt oder
beziehungsweise verschickt alles und
online live gehen verschiedene apps neu
machen ich habe mehr tik tok gemacht hat
mit 1,1 millionen follower in der korona
zeit dazu war ich glaube dass die leute
jetzt mehr im internet sind und dass für
die entfernung natürlich gut ist du
sprichst ja vorwiegend junge junge
frauen an
mit mit kosmetik mit mit viewty da
gibt's ja wahrscheinlich auch viele
mädchen die sagen und ich möchte so
werden wie du ich bin totaler fan von
dir
ich mache jetzt auch auf influenza
kannst du das den jungen mädchen
erzählen
es ist ein sehr harter weg kommt
natürlich drauf an was für ein mensch
man ist also jetzt auf meine art und
weise wie ich es gemacht habe ich bin ja
sehr gemobbt wurden weil ich halt eben
so toll dort operiert bin so freizügig
wollte man nicht so frei ziemlich
freizügig rumlaufen kommt darauf an was
man machen möchte aber wenn man in die
öffentlichkeit gehen will ist es sehr
schwierig als
man muss auf jeden fall sehr stark sein
und damit rechnen dass auch hält geben
wird und man muss einfach durch das
alles durchgehen es ist nicht einfach so
ok ich fange jetzt also nach oben wäre
es geht einfach so so so so und dann
kommt wieder in die krise und dann
läuft's nicht und blablabla also es ist
sehr viel arbeit für den kopf was heißt
arbeit für den kopf also inszeniert du
dich oder bist du halt doch so wie du
bist halt am anfang also bei mir ist es
so ich glaube bei vielen ist das so man
ist erstmal man selbst und dann
irgendwann kommt das geschäftliche dazu
und dann muss man natürlich gucken ok
welchen schritt mache ich jetzt wie
mache ich das jetzt aber bei mir ich bin
immer ich so deswegen habe ich auch
nicht so viele kooperationspartner die
andere im fenster die den ruf komplett
sauber halten aber das ist mir egal weil
meine marke es echt zu sein deswegen und
diese diese marke heißt ja du wirst ja
wahrscheinlich dann auch älter sozusagen
aber du planst auch dauerhaft wirklich
da weiterzumachen weil deine fans
wachsen mit dir und werden dann auch
eltern genau meint entsagen auch zu mir
wir wachsen mit dir auf und das ist auch
mega an und ich finde um so älter man
wird umso anderes gespürt man fühlt dass
geschäftsreisen und ich baue mir andere
dinge auf jetzt habe ich ein buch
herausgebracht hätte ich auch nie
gedacht dass ich auf tour gehe dass ich
mit meinem album auf 1 g früher hab ich
nicht mehr musik gemacht ich finde das
baut sich irgendwann später auch wer
weiß was ich in zwei jahren noch zu
machen und ist das eine glückssache dass
sich die dass sich die leute mögen oder
kann man da auch was tun also kann man
sich sagen sei empathisch sei freundlich
oder so gibt's noch mal so ein paar
geheimtipps wie wie bin ich quasi
plötzlich überall beliebt oder was er
man auch jungen menschen sagen
authenzität erzielte selbst also beliebt
sein ist bei mir schwierig also bei mir
war so am anfang wo ich glaube das ist
bei vielen so die ein bisschen an ecken
ich bin ein mensch der aneckt ich habe
immer über sexualität geredet ich freue
mich gezeigt ich war überhaupt nicht
beliebt aber dadurch dass ich eben nicht
beliebt war aber trotzdem weitergemacht
habe und den leuten gesagt habe ich
mache trotzdem weiter dadurch habe ich
meine fans bekommen weil design ist es
richtig cool dass sie weitermachen aber
jeder hat irgendwo ein traum und
wünschte sich auch einfach
weiterzumachen und ich glaube man
braucht einfach seine story man muss das
was man isst vermischen und das zu dem
machen was sympathisch macht und bei mir
ist es eben das durchhalten und jeder
ist anders
deswegen muss man gucken manche sind
sympathisch weil die total lustig sind
jede anders aber ich finde man sollte es
nicht übertreiben mit den unbedingt
sympathisch sein und gemocht werden weil
das merken die leute auch wenn man fähig
ist
also muss so ein zwischending finden
zwischen gemacht werden aber trotzdem an
selbst sein und man selbst sein bedeutet
nicht immer was gutes zu machen aber das
bedeutet auch dass zuzugehen beim jetzt
zum beispiel das immer so ein bisschen
in die gesellschaft rhein schon 2,4
millionen fans dann hast du noch mehr
millionen da und da wie ist denn so die
stimmung überhaupt so im land sagen die
leute ich bin so ich habe irgendwie so
ein crooner koller und du holst mich da
so raus oder wollen wir wollen die
lebens tipps haben wie siehst du die
stimmung insgesamt durch corona jetzt
bei den fans meine fans ist das so dass
dadurch dass ich mein buch
herausgebracht hat sehr glücklich dass
ich das buch lesen können also da sind
die sehr glücklich sagen er ist der
koran zeit habe ich was zu tun und
ansonsten eigentlich alles ganz normal
die finden es einfach nur schade dass
sie tun nicht weitergeht war bei mir ist
es schwierig weil ich ja auch künstlerin
bin mit musik also ich bin ja auch
rapperin und das ist schade für die
beiden sich tickets geholt und sich
gefreut und die tour war und das ist
sehr traurig dass ich sehr aufgeregt
aber ich habe die tour jetzt verschoben
und dann oder so die fans auch
einverstanden und sagen ich bin mit den
nachholtermin einverstanden und möchte
auch nicht mal geld wiederhaben und
genau also es war so ich hatte einen
auftritt in münchen und dann musste ich
irgendwie nur den halben auftritt durfte
ich nur spielen weil da genau da ist
alles so umgedreht wurde mit corona und
dann habe ich richtig angst gehabt dass
die sauer sind weil meine fans sind mir
sehr wichtig und was sie denken da habe
ich ein megaphon genommen mit allen
menschen die noch draufschlagen gesagt
es tut übels leichtes gibt an corinna
und ich werde die wiederholen wenn ihr
kommen wollt kommt bei teuren ticket
wenn jetzt zurückgeben wie geht s zurück
so und es erklärt man gibt es nicht
zurück man freut sich ja also ich würde
auch nicht zurückgehen da nämlich
nochmal ankämpfen es dazu wir haben das
thema ticket ärger oft schon diese
sendung gehabt das ist ja wirklich auch
eine tolle sache wenn man sagt wenn ihr
das zurückgeben wollte dann könnte es
zurückgeben ankämpft jetzt wirklich
vorbildlich obwohl man es ja jetzt gar
nicht mehr unbedingt in anspruch darauf
hat genau das ist wirklich eine tolle
sache und das zeigt ja auch die starke
bindung irgendwie zu den fans wenn die
fans ein nämlich die treue halten obwohl
sie genau wissen dass es auch anders
ginge dass es manche machen ja auch viel
stress und das spricht natürlich auch
für den künstler selber das ist ja so
toll funktioniert und das ist sowieso
finde ich das wichtigste erlebe ich
sollten im anwaltlichen täglichen leben
dass es immer so um den markenkern geht
das ist so grundlage jedes erfolge ist
dass man also genauer weiß worum es geht
und was man eigentlich will und dass man
eigentlich ein markenkern bildet und dem
auch treu bleibt und das sieht man dann
natürlich auch hier am wirtschaftlichen
erfolg der fans sind treu weil man
einfach eine treue träume denn umgeht
und einfach offen mit denen umgeht und
das ist genau das was im grunde genommen
jetzt die vielen menschen die davon
betroffen sind natürlich von diesem
konzert ausfallen beispielsweise reise
auswählen und so weiter
was eben einfordern ja absolut meine
frage ist gibt es auch fans die sagen
mit ich hab so probleme jetzt ich bin
des brit warum ich auf ja ich habe
wirklich so diesen corona cola kannst du
da so tipps geben wägen corinna naja so
auch so ein bisschen aus einer
schlechten laune heraus zu kommen was an
allen fenstern was ich denen sagen ist
unterschiedlich kommt immer darauf an
manchmal mache ich sexuelle beziehung
sagt dann könnt es euch einfach da
freuen sich aber allgemein sollte man es
einfach nicht zu krass ernst natürlich
natürlich sollte man auf alles achten
und vorsorgen und masken tragen aber man
sollte auch mal rausgehen einfach mal in
die sonne setzen oder auch wenn es mal
regnet einfach rausgehen autofahren das
mache ich immer ich setze mich ins auto
und einfach mal rum und einfach
versuchen das zu überstehen
wirklich ja-wort sich ins auto setzt das
manchmal gerne ja wie wir das gern auto
ja ich war einfach gerne rum musik am
besten noch meinen eigenen
diese platte ist ja perfekt aber ich
habe meine eigene sehr gerne weil ich
mache gerade mein zweites album und dann
ist es wirklich mega ist es zu hören bis
man hört aber ich versuche zu hören das
könnte die single sein was könnte
ankommen nur anmachen ich denke die
ganze sache also bis auf erfolgreich
verdienst entsprechend auch gut gibt's
dann leute ich sagen mensch kannst du
mir geld leihen ich habe probleme gibt
es da wirklich auch neid auf diesen auf
diesen reichtum auf jeden fall es gibt
immer leid was ich schade finde also
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel neidisch bin
dann bin ich positiv neidisch also dann
bin ich so cool ich will es auch ich
mache das auch aber ich kenne auch
menschen die sagen ich mir das auch aber
wie kann es sein dass sie das hat aber
ich hab das ja nur weil ich einfach
arbeite ja doch welche art und weise und
das kann eigentlich jeder erreichen
ob man jetzt schlecht anfängt oder nicht
hat sehr schlecht angefangen
also ich kam von ganz ganz unten ich
hatte gar keine möglichkeit irgendwas zu
machen
und natürlich kommen auch freunde damals
anja kannst du mir was laien blablabla
aber das erkennt man auch man erkennt
wer was möchte wenn ein freund von mir
was will gebe ich gerne aber wenn ich
erkenne warum ich person das will weil
die halt nur nicht ausnehmen will dann
dass und fühlst du dich reich bist du
millionärin
ich sage dazu nichts ich bin glücklich
dass ich geld habe ich bin glücklich
dass ich meine familie finanzieren kann
ich bin glücklich dass sie unabhängig
sind durch mich und ich fühle mich reich
aber ich fühle mich nicht nur reich
wegen geld sondern einfach diese ganze
liebe was ich alles bekomme ich habe
alles erreicht was ich wollte so ich
mache zwar weiter weil ich noch höher
möchte aber so gesehen habe ich alles
erreicht was ich wollte mir hat 100.000
follower gereicht man hätte ein auto
gereicht
ich bin einfach dankbar dass noch mehr
geworden ist sowieso auch das hast du
jetzt 2
und ja was sind deine ziele zehn
millionen oder was ist so du so die die
marke die erreicht werden wollen ich
gehe nicht mal nach followern oder
irgendwas meine ziele sind eher so mich
in verschiedenen jobs noch
auszuprobieren wie jetzt mit der musik
da bin ich sehr glücklich dass das
geklappt hat dann einfach mal
auszuprobieren neue projekte zu planen
solche sachen das finde ich viel cooler
da wünschen wir ja auch wirklich viel
erfolg dargestellt dazu in dieser
sendung war es hier
hier in unserem neuen studio vielen dank
katja glaser witze dankeschön